welcome back to new rockstars this is a
big question the show that gives you too
much information about how to get a home
loan in a post-flip society and how
batman
and myself can kick your ass in 127
different ways
i'm jessica clemens i'm hosting this big
question with the man of mystery
not mountain time no not montana
mp and the teach
just the mt what's going on i'm so
excited
to meet you i've heard nothing but
amazing things so this is going to be
great yes
shocking for everyone this is me and
mt's first time also like
meeting each other and then they were
like we're just going to have you guys
do an episode and
get into it we both talk a lot
let's do this let's let's do it i'm so
excited to just talk nerd let's do it oh
my gosh
i've been doing this my entire life
let's get started the falcon
and the winter soldier takes place six
months after the events of end game
and while new threats face our heroes at
seemingly every freaking
turn it looks like one of the biggest
problems facing society still
dealing with the implications of the
blip and half the population coming back
a former avenger can't even get a
freaking bank loan
from the small business association he's
uh
he's an avenger he's got a business plan
he has everything figured out he ran the
numbers
so our big question why is the world
still such a mess
six months after the events of endgame
and the blip that brought
half of the universe back i don't know
maybe it is me being like a horrible
person
but shouldn't we be better would be
better
i mean it sounds like everything should
be cool but like
it really isn't because like if you just
think about it like just
logically and just like how like crazy
the actual blip is
it's actually pretty it's intense it's
very like
like half of everyone just came back so
like it's gonna be
not as happy as everyone assumes it
would be
but no why is the world such a mess six
months after the events of
endgame and the blip that brought half
the universe back so philip and eric did
do a big question video about this about
a year ago where they discuss whether or
not
reversing the snap via the blip was a
mistake and they do make some valid
points in that video but
we're not here today to make that
reprehensible case we've since learned
some new information about the blip
itself from both wan division
and falcon in the winter soldier so we
wanted to go back to the topic of the
blip and dive into just how things could
just be so
topsy-turvy even though everyone's back
and everything should be cool right
i think it should be so the snap
performed by thanos in the battle of
wakanda wiped out half of all living
beings in the universe and set off five
years of insanity for everyone who
survived and we saw
a lot of this in the first part of any
game like empty streets
desolate cities overgrown yards just
overall just
depression it's everything's just sad
but on the bright side with you know
half of humanity gone
at least you know it was probably a lot
easier to buy like a ps5
so at least some people are happy are
you even buying it at that point why
don't you just steal it
honestly yeah i mean like you're in a
post-apocalyptic society and like
why not just you know just loot it's
totally fine so the people left behind
by the snap were forced to cope with
this new reality and very few people
expected
any of the people who vanished to ever
come back because why would you
they just did so society would
eventually just adjust to this new
reality where the people who were
snapped
were snapped for good now think about
that moment when everyone suddenly comes
back i mean
we as the audience got to see the
avengers work hard traveling through
time
doing their you know their time travel
shenanigans putting the pieces back
together but for regular folks regular
people
inside of the mcu your regular joe
schmoes their reality was a lot more
different because one second everyone's
just chilling and but in the next second
it's dead people palooza it's like half
of everyone that has ever existed is
just back so this is what we saw
with monica rambo and when she blipped
back in one division it was very
jarring it was very like that was one of
the craziest scenes in all of the mcu i
was very emotionally affected with that
scene and in spider-man far from home
they played that blip for laughs
i think that was more drastic because it
was the marching band
that one seems way more chaotic also
calling it a dead people palooza
why would you ever call it that i mean
that's essentially what it was i mean
it's not a festival you make it sound
like it's a concert
i mean if it's i mean it's a pretty
great day i mean if
like half of humanity's coming back i'm
like it's a pollutants of dead people
let's rejoice
that's the dead people dance oh my god i
can't wait for dead people to lose that
everybody get your short shorts
and your water bottles it's 104 degrees
in indio california
it's dead people palooza baby you
thought you thought
universal horror nights was a show wait
for dead people
i don't know what i'm saying i don't
know what i'm saying i'm uh
i'm very disturbed anyway continuing but
you have to imagine for the rest of the
world it was a very frantic and chaotic
experience with a lot of people who
survived the snap
possibly reliving a lot of the trauma of
that day when everyone disappeared which
would make a lot of sense it's a very
not great time
now cut to falcon in the winter soldier
now it's been six months and you can see
the hints of the cultural divide that
exists between those who were snapped
and those who stayed behind existing now
this seems to bubble up between sam and
his sister when they discuss finances in
the first episode she presents that sam
is going to tell her what to do now that
he hasn't been around for five years of
all the
depression and insanity but of course
those who were snapped
would have the same type of resentment
because they didn't choose to die like
no one
chooses to be murdered by thanos like
that wasn't their choice
so unless you're me i want to be
wrecked by thanos
unless you're this girl i think you mean
daddy fanthan
i mean come on so gross but i love it
i'm here for it
it's literally the name he was born with
i hear um it was on his birth
certificate i saw it
oh yeah cause you you delivered thanos
you you alone delivered thanos oh yeah i
was there i was on
yeah i was on titan it was a it was a
pretty crazy day uh
his mom tried to stab him
anyway let us take a look at different
areas of society where things still
aren't better than they were before this
nap now that half the population has
been blipped back because things
are still kind of a mess so let's talk
about jobs everyone's talking about jobs
these days
jobs is a big thing but jobs probably
got really
complicated post blip in the marvel
cinematic universe because lots of jobs
probably shifted during the snap they
probably needed
to fill key roles to keep utilities like
power water and sewage
still working and we saw an endgame when
scott lang was walking around san
francisco
that the power was still on but had a
lot of houses with overgrown yards
and still some like really dirty streets
and just like it see
it kind of seems like the snap happened
and then like chaos happened and then
people just kind of left some of the
chaos in the streets which is like
because you see like
i believe a moped just in the streets
just like chilling there like it crashed
and yeah there were definitely some
dirty streets but there was still some
reliable infrastructure which
is good to hear because infrastructure
is nice
for society i hear oh word on the street
is infrastructure we really need that
yes
i mean like people all the kids seem to
be talking about infrastructure and how
cool it is how do you do fellow kids i'm
just like hey
hey this is pretty good we should
probably keep doing this
infrastructure thing anyway
so think about this imagine you get
snapped and then you come back
looking for your job do you do you get
to keep your job should you keep your
job
my job as a comedian and just like in
general
i'm sure if i come back someone's gonna
take my type 5.
someone can take my stand-up gig i'm
okay
but you come back and someone steals all
of your material that's just
oh see no that would piss me off and
that's something that would happen
so if i left my journal back and someone
broke into my house for some reason
took my great boots and then i came back
and saw them doing it live
i would fight them
yeah we call the avengers
[Laughter]
spider-man this guy's stealing my bits
he's killing my
scripts i had a great story about
losing my wallet one day and he took it
yeah that's what the avengers are for
they literally are here for me
avengers
[Music]
falcon said that they're here for
goodwill so like hey
that's there's no better will than
avenging someone who stole your comedic
notes really
mt is a lawyer nowadays okay okay so
jessica let me ask you a question so
if someone took your job and they were
actually better at it
how how would how would you feel how
would that make you feel
obviously i'd be upset but if i blipped
back i'd probably kill them
no i wouldn't kill them i wouldn't kill
them that's illegal but i would do
something i would do
something about it maybe like push trip
them trip them so they break their ankle
i mean like there's plenty of there's
plenty of things you can do to people
without killing them jessica we could
feel like we could hide feces somewhere
in their home
you know just they won't know that it's
there they'll just be like what is that
smell
they're like it smells like someone
pooped under my bed but i can't
fight it
exactly it's that long-term mental
torture
i leave just like a dog poop in a bag
and put it on fire
every day on their doorstep and ring the
bell and run away
i just do like their car i'm like giving
my job back
it depends on what job it is if it's new
rock stars i will have to fight them
listen jessica i want you to know if you
ever become blipped back from a
cosmic act of terrorism i want you to
know that you can call me and i will
fight whoever replaces you
with okay he will tag team violence this
man
but anyway we're done let's talk about
finances because
let's say you're dead for five years and
you you're just not around in general
because you do not exist
is your credit score frozen like what
happens with that like i don't
understand
you know your credit score would go down
yeah it would probably plummet i mean
you can't plumb it from zero so
whoa this is worthless
don't say that your credit score is
probably so much nicer than
so many people's um i uh i eat food off
the street jessica i uh
i just had a delicious banana peel
earlier my credit is just
abysmal jessica how dare you assume i
live the life of a raccoon
[Laughter]
i'm actually inside of a ymca right now
so uh you know
in a couple of minutes
[Laughter]
okay like did the money that you had in
a savings account accrue interest for
five years and like
if you had a mortgage when you were
snapped are you penalized for not making
a payment for five years like there's a
lot of things
that could go terribly wrong for people
that come back from the snap
the last thing i think about when i come
back is my finances
yeah i'm probably taking a nice long
nature walk and just
just appreciating being alive and not
you know dust particles
i'm not trying to think about my college
loans after i come back
yeah i mean i'm not thinking about those
now those are just like you know just
college loans aren't real that's all
just that's all fiction that's a
mythical creature
there's realism unicorns i'm not paying
them
edit that out i'm so nervous the irs
will say this
i don't need i don't need that on me
right now i don't need that on my
conscience
you said you were going to commit tax
evasion i didn't say that
i just said i can't pay it also
my film degree has done nothing
and business communications i'm kelly
kapoor
the business if you had a mortgage
when you were snapped are you penalized
for not making a payment for five years
and like if you go back to the first
episode of falcon on the winter soldier
falcon and his sister are struggling to
get a loan
when their parents have been like loyal
customers to this bank for forever
but because sam hasn't had an income for
five years all of a sudden it's so
difficult to get along
ain't that how it would be jessica ain't
that how it be when a couple
sorry we're not gonna make it about race
we gonna say that sorry hey
hey in that episode low key in that
episode i was like
i was like i was like look at it
exactly i'm just like i was like ain't
nothing new over here
ain't none new over here that's more
than the money this is what happens when
you have two black people hosting big
questions
we tell you the truth we tell you about
what's good
not too good if we're not talking about
how we can't get freaking bank loans
we're talking about blue marble we're
talking about blue marble or bank loan
listen blue marble is more important
than bank loans honestly i feel like
every bank teller should be talking
about blue marvel
when they're trying to to give loans
because he's the backbone of our society
jessica i just want you to know
he is i need one of those two things
either bank loan or blue marble and it
looks like i'm gonna get
probably the bank loan but but i want
blue marvel to show up
don't worry he's gotta come he's too
like
the ultimate is one of my favorite like
comic marvel teams so like
he's got it he's got it also okay sorry
side note side note i
just read the comic book where falcon
turns into a werewolf
when do people just start turning into
animals
[Applause]
i was so confused i was okay
i mean it was a shout out to werewolf
cat werewolf cap from the past
but like it was wild and i loved it and
i was like dude i feel like they should
just keep it
like why not just have them turn into a
wolf at some times when he's out i don't
need that
don't say it don't you say it left
it just made it too confusing i was like
okay i'm just gonna put this
issue down and i'm just gonna skip it i
was like this is too crazy for me
you know it's the filler issue when
they're doing something crazy like that
it's like all right we're just gonna do
this for like three issues and then
we're gonna 100 and we have to consider
the people who returned
who want to reclaim their property
people
there's probably a ton of homeowners
that came back like oh
why is there an old lady uh inside of my
home
when i lived there with myself and my
video games
i had to beat an old lady with a stick
to get these but a lot of state
governments
actually do have a process for
reclaiming property for a person who is
listed as
vanished or like disappeared but returns
afterwards
for example in california you have five
years to reclaim
property but in other states it takes
less time okay i live in an apartment
so you should be fine i mean you'd
probably have to go apartment hunting
but you know
obviously with the whole house situation
it's a lot easier getting a new
apartment than
you know finding someone for your home
now i'm only going to stay in apartments
because i'm now afraid of a blip
happening
why not i mean if there's even a one
percent chance
of a blip happening don't invest don't
commit don't commit to being a homeless
don't invest
you heard it here you guys waste time
don't invest don't invest
if we believe there's even a one percent
chance we have to take it as an absolute
certainty
you heard it from mt take your money out
of the housing market
let it crash let it crash
okay you guys now to the real business
we can make it crash again and again and
again
and again and again and again folks boom
and like what if your family sold your
house when you were snapped or your
personal belongings
you sold my dead bird to a blind kid do
you have the rights
to get your stuff back finders keepers
wow so like if someone
bought all of your stuff and like or
like someone had all of your stuff you
wouldn't like trying to get it back
because i'd probably steal from someone
else you steal for me fine i mean other
people have plenty of other stuff so
i'll steal from them you live in the
ymca why would i steal from you
exactly this is community stuff like you
can't steal from the community but of
course we have to talk about
governments in world governments and
alliances and treaties and all that
because it sounds like during the five
years
um during this like the post-snap world
the world sort of became more
unified in a way because torres says in
episode one that the flag smashers think
the world was better
during the blip and they want to live in
a world unified without borders
which you know sounds nice it sounds
like a nice thing but
you know they're just not going about it
in the best of ways
which is unfortunate and like you know
we we have seen this happen in
the real world in times of extreme peril
i mean whether or not
it's like a terrorist attack or a
natural disaster countries
tend to like at least temporarily put
aside their differences in order to deal
with like an immediate threat
um that they need to address even right
now during the cover 19 pandemic like
countries
have worked together in such really
unique ways that we haven't really seen
before which is really cool
it would be nice if we just did that in
general it'd be cool it
takes a horrible thing to happen for us
to actually come together
some countries may have been in much
worse conditions than others which
required the world to work together more
which
would make sense because there's a lot
of like inequalities in the world fun
fact
there's probably need some teamwork
after such a really
just drastic event as such as the snap
teamwork make a dream work but now that
half of humanity is suddenly back again
it sounds like countries are going back
to their isolationist
mentalities like with when rhodey was
talking to sam in the first episode
and he remarked that the allies are now
enemies and alliances are torn apart
and everything's just chaos after the
snap so things are just
not looking super stable but like you're
just new things are
like lines are being sort of redrawn in
a way um so that's
interesting to see i'm very interested
to see what a post-snap world is going
to look like in the mcu because
there's a lot of stuff like this that we
need to consider because we didn't
really get to see it with one division
but i'm really looking forward to that
part and falcon and winter soldier of
being like this is the
it's like it's like this is a horrible
example it's like getting the purge from
the perspective of
the hard like the lower class people
whereas one division was like
these people live in a suburb they're
not really paying attention to anything
else
so i'm really excited to see that in
falcon and winter soldier being like
this is how i would have been
[Laughter]
no i agree i'm 110 that's a yes i 100
agree but in terms of like the military
and the world militaries
fighting forces were decimated around
the globe after the snap and with that
nations probably needed to like put
their wars on pause it's like hey
we lost half of our army could you can
we not fight for just a minute but we
just
yeah okay let's just work together all
right they said no we can assume that
the us military was debriefed on thanos
but
was that info shared with other
countries i mean it's possible that some
were just waiting around for more people
to suddenly disappear
and like now that you have your full
military back like do you go back to
being more defensive and less
accommodating to foreign countries
or like do you just keep that
relationship going like it's really
a lot of really interesting things to
consider and if you had soldiers
overseas in combat situations that were
snapped away
it's possible they blipped back in an
area that they should not be
like like imagine the spy just like
blips back into like the middle of like
like i don't know a dinner party for the
people he was spying with he's like
oh hello oh my god
i would give up everything i'd be like i
have to go see my family i'm not
actually like
supposed to be here i'm a spy
i'm the spy what yeah i would just be
completely up like listen like we
i was doing like some weird sketchy
five years ago but like i
am just glad to be alive i was just i
didn't feel anything for a long time
i want to smell some flowers so i'm
leaving i will
lay out the names and codes if i can go
smell a flower right just for this the
sweet smell of a rose i would
give up the codes for the sweet smell of
the rose they say a rose
is a rose as a rose but that's not quite
true
that's why i'm not a spy you don't have
to torture me it doesn't take much for
me
to snitch out a bunch of things i feel
like all you have to do is like
do something mildly annoying i'll be
like okay i'll say it jesus
just stop just stop being weird
everybody get away from the mirror
they've checked all this paint for lead
right do you feel any air coming out of
that vent i got nothing okay i'll say it
jesus
now let's talk about politics because
everyone loves talking about politics
we don't know exactly what people in
powerful government positions were
snapped away but we have to assume
that some were and there may have been
some secession issues that move to
people around its newer higher positions
of government like
if some people who returned were elected
officials do they get their old
positions back
hayward technically took over for monica
technically right because he was acting
director
so i guess people don't get their
positions back you move your meat you
lose your seat as they say
you move your meat you lose your seat
exactly that's not
that you move your meat you lose that's
uh yeah it's in the bill of rights
have you have you read the bill of
rights i i guess i haven't read the bill
of rights
i hate it i hate it i hate it i hate it
and we can assume that the us government
had to enact some massive legislation
that dealt with the snap including
classifying those who disappeared as
vanished or missing and not deceased and
considering how slow the government can
be to enact legislation it makes sense
that they haven't figured out everything
post blip it's possible that they're
still working to undo some of the
legislation that was passed during the
snap
but it's all you know it's gonna be uh
a legislative uh kerfuffle if you will
now let's talk about society as a whole
because those who were here for the five
years
um during like after the snap lived
through
a lot and it made sense that they would
resent the people who have returned
because those people
who were blipped didn't get to live
through those five years like they
didn't know the trauma
of losing loved ones and seeing the
world collapse and restructure
so you kind of just have to view it from
that perspective because there's
probably just a lot of just resentment
there even though there really sort of
shouldn't be but
i understand from where they're coming
from but those who were blipped
might resent the people who weren't
because they lost those five years after
all like they
died so their families and friends aged
five years and probably moved on
with lives without them and spouses may
have remarried and like
it's just really complicated and really
messy and i really sort of want the mcu
to tackle this specific issue
of like you know relationships sort of
like being like
really weird and awkward now because
like now my sort of ex is back and like
she we were gonna get married and like i
love her
and like i found it i have this new
person now and i love them like what are
we gonna do
um my little brother is now older than
me um he can drink legally and i
can't i need someone to figure this out
wait a minute i'm still gonna call do i
call him my little brother still or
what's going on now
there's a lot of questions about
logistics i have about this i think he's
your little big brother now
no he's still my little brother to me
honestly i'd be the same way if my
little brother became older than me
i wouldn't i wouldn't take any of his
i'd still beat him up
that's the thing i don't care that
you're bigger than me now
i'm still gonna kick your ass
[Applause]
and there's a lot of culture that did or
did not happen in those five years and
it sounds like
most of like the major league sports
stopped or at least like the mets did
and maybe that's a good thing i mean who
knows but there may have been
still been movies tv and other forms of
entertainment and art
that were created during the snap and
people who blipped back
would feel the need to catch up on some
or all of this like imagine
all of like i don't know how many
seasons of grey's anatomy would come out
during those five years probably 17
seasons roughly a lot
if i was a spy that materialized
in the middle of a dinner party of a
place that i was spying on five years
ago i'd be like
fetch me your finest chromecast i must
binge
all of grey's anatomy
on this new peacock app that they keep
talking about i don't
know what this is i need the of the
pee or else i can't watch anatomy of
greys
by thunder rhymes bring me your finest
peacock here
[Laughter]
i would be like mt don't talk to me like
that
you know i'm just gonna get you can you
can use my smart tv
stop acting like you're a genius
that's just who i am as a person that
probably is
i would not be surprised i will
occasionally just go into like a fancy
voice like
i need to use the bathroom one toilet
paper please
one toilet paper please um anyway
in regards to captain america it seems
that people are aware
that captain america participated in
something that reversed the snap
and then went missing but they don't
really know the whole
deal which is really interesting and we
know that the public is aware
of thanos or at least the people in
steve rogers support group do anyway
but does the public know about the
infinity stones
or that thanos came to earth through a
quantum tunnel or like any of those
details like we don't know specifically
how much the avengers told the public
about all the craziness that went down
because like would the like public even
understand because like we're getting
into quantum
time physics and all of that and like
we as the audience to this day are
probably are still confused
like okay like what we're doing split
timelines now or like we
so like if you go back in time it
doesn't affect the past it's very
confusing
i just want to know where my stimulus
check is that that is it
do i still get it in the blip do i never
get it through the blue
[Laughter]
excuse me i have not received mine yet
and i'm going to make it everybody's
problem now
it is everybody's problem here the first
words after you get
backed give me the stimi where's my
stimulus where's my stimming
and then i'm like i'm really strong for
some reason i don't know what must
honestly i was like that like like
literally the day before i got my
stigmas i was like
i'm about to act up i'm about to act up
right now if i don't get that stimulus
check give me that stimmy strength
i'm the only person that hasn't gotten
one yet i guess
so everybody has come back and now the
world seems even more perilous than it
was during the five years of the blip
it's easy to see
how this total upheaval of the world
status quo was going to have long
lasting effects on society
but what does this mean for the events
of falcon and the winter soldier going
forward like will the
majority of the public begin to align
with the ideals
of the flag smashers will it become
radicalized like the flag smashers
will us agent john walker be embraced by
adoring fans or be shunned away
as a weak reboot that he is because he
is a weak reboot he's like when joe
took over blue's clues from steve that's
literally how i feel
exactly betrayed joe nothing wrong with
joe nothing's wrong with joe listen
i love joe but i'm saying initially
initially okay no
see now you're coming for joe it's more
like kimberly brown
in halloweentown when she was replaced
in halloweentown when they went to
college with that other girl that
clearly isn't her
but had the same butt chin in halloween
time
with that yep they tried to slide with
that and i noticed they were like them
kids ain't gonna notice but we did
we knew yeah we did notice that's
actually a better
um example let's go with that one i turn
i said
boop i turned it off and i said i'll go
back to calabar's revenge
i sent an electronic email i asked my
mother if i could hop onto the computer
and i was like i need to tell disney
channel about what i feel
i sent a long message to them uh they
never got back to me they actually
banned me they never got back
all disney parks um anyway will us agent
john walker be embraced by adoring fans
or be shunned away as a weak reboot
unshun yeah that sounds good
rishon will sam ever get that boat in
decent enough shape to run some charters
on the weekend
we will have to wait and see i
personally would like to see sailor sam
but hey um that's just my um
wants for the show i i only want to see
him sail the boat i don't want to really
see him do anything else
i just want nautical adventures with sam
and uh bucky really
oh i just want to see sam say look at me
look at me
i am the captain now i'm the cup to know
honestly if he doesn't do that
when he actually becomes captain america
shut the whole production
down i'm canceling my disney plus
subscription it's just like you had one
job kevin
you had one job just to say look at me
i'm the captain now
because he's the first black captain
america he has to say it
sorry he has to say it he's a captain
and he owns that ship now so he's
look at me look at me i am the captain
now okay so
kevin feige we're just saying two black
nerds said that this is okay to do
so you have to do it now you have you
have the you have the permission
you have the permission from jessica
clemens and mt the only two people he
just whips out his like wallet he's like
oh no i have a black pass
yeah he goes i am captain now
i only do it for this one line i don't i
don't give it out often it's very
i keep that close to me i do not
hand that card out just to anybody
okay so now we're going to dive into our
bite-sized questions next but first of
course we got to get a word from some of
the folks that help us
make big question and bring it to you
every day in a week
starting with minch mobile now if you've
ever dealt with a big
wireless providers you know that there's
always a catch right so when you first
hear
that mint mobile offers premium wireless
service starting at just 15 bucks a
month
you're probably waiting for the catch
but let me let you in on a secret here
there isn't a catch there is none mid
mobile secret sauce is that they are the
first company to sell
wireless service online only and they
pass on those savings
to you and here at new rockstars philip
switched to mint mobile and he loves it
like he saves more than 20 bucks a month
from his old plan and he gets to use
a 5g network for just 15 bucks a month
it's literally insane mint mobile offers
premium wireless for just 15 bucks a
month
and all plans come with unlimited talk
text and high-speed data
delivered on the nation's largest 5g
network
use your phone with any mobile plan and
keep your same phone number it's
literally
so convenient and i love that you can't
keep your same phone number because
i've had my same phone number for
forever and i have no plans on giving it
up
i'm literally going to take my phone
number to my grave you can call me
in the casket and if you're not 100
satisfied mint mobile has a seven day
money back guarantee so you can just you
can don't worry
you can rest easy switch to mid mobile
and get premium wireless service
starting at just 15 bucks a month to get
your new wireless plan for just 15 bucks
a month
and get the plan shipped to your door
for free go to mintmobile.com
big q that's mintmobile.com bigqueue
cut your wireless bill to 15 bucks a
month at mintmobile.com
bigq do it today you will save so much
money and you will have
amazing cell phone service and if you
have a job
you're an athlete in the sport of
business and athletes need good
equipment
you want a versatile look with timeless
style
for that there's cuts clothing cuts
takes a plain teen sprinkle it with that
tony stark spice they use the latest
fabric technology to make their shirts
and it shows
phillip has several cut shirts and loves
them they look great and have a really
nice athletic fit
he says there's no other shirt that fits
as well as cuts and i know what you're
thinking
phillip looks great with his shirt off
but you know what's even better
when he wears a shirt and those shirts
are from cuts clothing
in 2016 cuts founder steve borelli set
out to create clothes ready for every
occasion the modern man faces
he reinvented the t-shirt and made the
gq magazine calls
the only shirt worth wearing you hear
that philip
the only shirt worth wearing
put on a shirt we don't need to see your
washboard abs all the time
cuts is premium with a purpose each
piece of clothing is designed with
custom engineered fabric expertly graded
for the perfect fit
arming you for every challenge and
opportunity it's not just a lifestyle
it's not just clothing it's office
leisure apparel
for the sports of business get 15 off
your first order by going to
cutsclothing.com
big question i think it's going to be
right here if the editors are making me
look like a full pointing to my
crotch i'm gonna be upset that's
cutsclothing.com
big question for 15 off the only shirt
worth wearing folks ask phillip let's
get to our bite size question do you
want to give it to me you want to serve
it up
serve it up cold bite size question
number one let's get it
how many different fighting styles has
batman
mastered there's a factoid floating
around that batman has mastered 127
different martial arts which is just
literally insane even if he was devoted
to practicing martial arts
every day from the ages 14 to 30 he
still wouldn't have enough time to
master 127 different martial arts
some of the faster programs still take
at least a year to master
but bruce wayne like we know is no
ordinary man he does have a genius level
intelligence so that makes him more
adept at learning these fighting skills
in the comics batman trained with master
kirigi to learn taekwondo
master tu chen li to learn kung fu and
shihan matsuda to learn multiple
disciplines which probably included
karate
aikido and judo he's also had other
fighting teachers over the years like
ted grant the master assassin david kane
alaskan hunter willie doggett giovanni
john zatara
henry dukart and of course uh raz all
ghoul so yes
batman is very accomplished fighter and
knows all sorts of fighting skills from
boxing to ninjutsu to krav maga
capoeira it has been stated in the
comics that batman has mastered any
fighting skill he's learned and the
results of these skills
seem to match the sentiment he's held
his ground with some of dc's best
fighters including roswell ghoul bronze
tiger and lady shiva so which martial
arts has batman
mastered oh pretty much all of them well
probably not quack foo
though which means howard the duck is
coming to whup that ass
batman
whoop that ass bruce
i also i love howard the duck so don't
mess with howard the duck y'all
he'll beat your ass him and me give me
the second give me the second
second question all right so question
number two
could yondu udanta's yaka arrow pierce
and possibly kill thanos if it were
going fast enough
uh perfect question great question
everybody has this question
i've had this question as the question
points out yondu's arrow is made of
yaakov which is a rare sound sensitive
metal found from the centurion home
world yes
yondu is centurion the arrow is
controlled both by the fin
and the user's wears on his head and
through whistling hence why it is sound
sensitive metal and i know what you guys
are thinking
the arrow is actually with his heart
that's how he moves it
he also uses it with the breath between
his lips
it's sound sensitive metal y'all we know
the arrow's strong enough to pierce
drax's super dense tough skin
even when wielded by an amateur like
kraglin it is safe to assume that
yondo's arrow could pierce thanos skin
that is if you're even able to get that
arrow close enough to thanos let's
remember
that he's an accomplished fighter with
super quick reflexes
you would have to be so quick to pierce
thanos with that arrow even without him
and having the infinity stones it's
probably best to aim for his eye though
yeah the eyeball is the perfect place to
aim for thanos because
it's the most it's usually the most less
uh like less thick it's not as thick as
thanos thick ass purple skin so
definitely forget to mention thanos is a
thick
thick thick thick daddy he is the
thickest purple alien i've ever done
seen and i've seen a lot of thick aliens
jessica look at a bowl of
[Laughter]
those are my type of men i like them big
and dangerous
um the juvenile i like
him hey big and crazy hey you you
you you like a man that can that has
force i i don't i don't blame you i
haven't that's uh that's that's a high
priority
they're trying to kill everyone and
and with that being said let's let's get
into our box of scraps
a box of scraps so our box of scraps
question
is in falcon on the winter soldier sam
looks like he's really considering
running that fishing boat now what would
be your
backup dream job jessica what would be
the dream job of your dreams
tell me i don't know a farmer honestly i
like gardening a lot and i know that's
not the equivalent to like
owning your entire farm but i've always
wanted to own chickens and goats
so like yeah i think farming
would absolutely be my dream job
honestly
i mean that's really good i really do
like that i mean thanos was all about
that that was his backup
after everything went down so he's like
let me get me a farm on a different
planet so
you know basically that's that's not bad
that's i
think farming's really chill i mean i
haven't done farming but i've seen
people play farmville
many years ago um it seems pretty easy
so
it's a good home
[Laughter]
but what's your dream job what's your
backup dream job i don't know probably
like owning like a comic book shop
i feel like that'd be really cool just
to like be able to sell comics and then
like
have like nerds come in oh man it would
be so cool to just
talk comics all day with a bunch of like
book nerds i love that and i take mine
back because now i want to say owning a
barcade because i actually do want to
own a barcade one day
i love barking oh my gosh i want to do
like an 80s let's
mess our ideas together we couldn't we
could sell comic books you could
but you can't spill your drinks we
should make a comic book barcade
yo listen we shouldn't have said this
idea in front of thousands of people
because now we're gonna get marksmen
we gotta copyright it we gotta get yeah
we gotta no one zuckerberg us or we will
sue you with our
lawyers yeah with our lawyers our
lawyers on twitter
they're all girls oh our twitter
first time stamping best lawyers you
better watch out you better not
do it i know so many lawyers on tick
tock and i will reach out to them
and i will sue this is a great idea
and it could be in boston it could be so
many people
so many lawyers on tick tock giving me
hacks and stuff honestly that's
genuinely a good idea
okay yo you better start it and you like
i better be there for the ribbon cutting
i'm gonna hold on to this and none of
you guys steal our damn idea
and that was today's episode of
big question we are wrapping it up here
we had said so many bits you guys that
you could eat up
and you can throw at me online uh
thank you mt for joining me for this
episode
mt where do they find you at what's your
handles where do they look for you
well uh you can find me on the streets
of boston being very sad and depressed
and eating banana peels
but online you can find me um on
instagram
youtube and twitter at mastertainment um
that's where i am twitter's mostly where
i just say all of my nonsense so if you
want to talk nerdy with me come see me
there
and just like following mt in the
streets of boston you can follow me and
here in the streets of la
i'm always at the grove and no i'm not i
lied do not go to the grove looking for
me i'm never there
but you can follow me at lulu underscore
clemens on twitter lulu clemens
everywhere
else uh follow new rockstars send us
your big question using the hashtag
bigquestion
subscribe to this podcast feed and give
us a nice rating and review
and tell us what it's like to also live
like a raccoon
uh subscribe to new rockstars here and
on youtube hit that notification bell
make sure you call your mom because mt's
coming to
swipe her up ah it's true um hide your
moms
because i'm coming i'm a mom daddy mt is
coming
i can't i can't good night goodbye
[Music]
you